you
so welcome to the Swedish Academy here
in Stockholm and this short interview
with the Permanent Secretary of the
Academy mr. Horace stated on mr. Assange
why Sean Nevada stofflet les yeux
this year it's nothing nothing about him
that makes it particularly necessary to
having this year but you know the Nobel
Committee in the Academy we work with a
long perspective we prepare our
decisions for years and years we've been
reading little SEO for well at least a
decade and there is no practical
consideration in making him a winner
this year and and you must remember that
all this phosphorus has been as a result
over of a certain interview by The
Associated Press that came after the
real discussion and the real decision by
the Academy said it has nothing to do
with ecology yes he has become a very
modern writer which he really wasn't
from the beginning because when he
started to cultivate those interests
they weren't as topical as they are
today
ecology wasn't very much talked about in
the 1970s but he was attracted to that
because of his interest in foreign
cultures and he soon came to Mexico
early he came to Mexico early and and he
with engines in in Panama for four years
he learned a language and and he
initiated himself into the amount of
thought and thereby he has become a
writer who stands a bit outside of the
Western civilization
he's not really a typical Frenchman he
is a nomadic writer he doesn't really
belong anywhere he's been moving around
throughout his his area from France to
North Africa to America to the Indian
nation and other places and he is
equally at home everywhere well I think
his preoccupation with these subjects
has mostly been a room of a moral nature
that is a question of identifying an
essential way of life that is not as
denaturation and silly as as the normal
existence of of normal Westerners and he
has given many expressions to that both
of a satirical kind but also were
utopian kind he has tried to sketch what
our community would be like that
discarded all the
sort of deficiencies the modern
technical civilization and and he's done
that sometimes perhaps in a way there is
to be too beautiful I can agree but but
very often yes he has had a point this
formula that you find the will of Alfred
Nobel it played a role in the beginning
of history the price I say up to 1920 or
something but dozen today because we
consider a World Series literature to be
overnight erection so it's not
particularly because of that formulation
that we give the price to literacy an
era thank you for our saying Don if you
would like more information go to the
official website of the mobile
foundation WWL price org that is
nobelprize.org thank you